willkommen zur heutigen sitzung ganz zu
beginn möchte ich sie hinweisen auf ein
extra für sie erstelltes video nämlich
über die frage wie man haus arbeiten im
fach philosophie schreibt oder auch
formatiert und hier sehen sie dieses
video
sie können also das einfach auf die
lowcost sich mal zu gemüte führen
und dann werden sie hier instruiert wie
sie also da vorgehen müssen um falls sie
es noch nicht wissen eine philosophische
hausarbeit schreiben als sie sehen hier
meinen aus zeige dann auch die daneben
wandert und edel dann hier im laufe
dieses circa 10 minütigen videos alles
genau erklärt darf ich fragen mal kurz
wer von ihnen das ganze schon mal was
ich an gesehen hat wenn man kurz melden
noch nicht ja dann können sie das gerne
machen falls sie es wollen ich verlinke
ist auch mit dem video der heutigen
sitzung
so jetzt aber zurück zur eigentlichen
sache nämlich zu diesem netten herrn
hier zu rehberg song ein philosoph des
späten neunzehnten und frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts und zu seiner
schrift zeit und freiheit die aber im
französischen original so gar nicht hieß
haben sie meine zusammenfassung bekommen
da habe ich den originaltitel darauf
geschrieben man hat dieser schrift
diesem titel im deutschen gegeben weil
man einfach nicht ganz schlau draus
wurde was jetzt der bergsommer
eigentlich vor augen hatte also darüber
schrieb er schreibt über so verschiedene
themen und man hat versucht die mit zwei
begriffen
abzudecken das trifft natürlich nur
bedingt zu und ganz wichtig für die
beschäftigung mit bergs und das werden
wir heute noch mal machen und dann
werden wir in der zweiten hälfte auf
martin heiliger eingehen wir werden
jetzt heute einen schnellen durchlauf
machen nachdem wir in der letzten
sitzung die wichtigsten gedanken und
sehr bereits vergegenwärtigt haben ganz
entscheidend für den zeitbegriff bei
bergson ist der begriff der dauer- oder
französisch die dauer
was macht eigentlich die dauer haus wir
haben hier ein ereignis wir haben hier
ein ereignisse hier ein ereignis und
hier ein ereignis zum beispiel einen
pendelschlag an uhr eigentlich besteht
ja aus wenn man in teilten ganz
verschiedene sequenzen unendlich vielen
punkten
meinetwegen auch zeitpunkten und jetzt
ist hier die frage was macht es dass wir
eine bewegung nicht nur als etwas
punktuelles verstehen sondern dass wir
hier übergänge hinbekommen und zwar so
dass sich die eigentlich überlappen
dass sie also dass die sich einmal sagte
so den staffelstab in die hand geben es
kommt jetzt hier einen moment und der
übergibt seinen stab sein staffelstab
dem nächsten moment also es gibt ebenso
das kleine überbrückungen und somit
bekommen wir hier in der zeit dauer
nicht nur etwas additives das einfach
aneinander gesetzt wird hier noch ein
zeitpunkt hier noch ein zeitpunkt hier
noch ein zeitung sind das ganze ist wie
bergsommer sagt organisch zu verstehen
ist also etwas fast schon lebendiges wir
werden das gleich noch ein bisschen
genauer sehen er bringt auch ein schönes
beispiel ein
die eine melodie eine melodie ist
organisiert und so ist auch unsere zeit
erfahrung organisiert und die zeit
erfahrung liegt jetzt nicht einfach nur
so objektiv vor sondern sie hängt mit
unserem bewusstsein ganz eng zusammen
also dass wir überhaupt so eine
organisation hinbekommen von etwas was
uns von außen gegeben wird man kann sich
natürlich fragen gibt es nicht auch
innere zeit empfindung innere zeitdauer
die mit nichts äußeren verbunden ist
aber jedenfalls bei bergson ist es so da
gibt es immer etwas äußeres seriosität
hin dass das ist zum beispiel ein pendel
was sich gleichmäßig bewegt und dann
gibt es noch unser bewusstsein oder ein
ding auch unser selbstbewusstsein
jedenfalls willkommen allgemein sagen
und was damit eine verbindung gebracht
hat und erst dann entsteht dieses
phänomen der dauer
ich schreibe hin phänomen das ist
nämlich ein phänomenologie also einer
der die phänomene die erscheinungen wie
sie uns erscheint das was in unserem
bewusstsein auftaucht und das ist zum
beispiel eben die dauer die frage ist ob
die zeitdauer ein gegenstand unseres
bewusstseins ist oder ob es nicht eher
die form unseres bewusstseins ist das
alles was im bewusstsein auftaucht nur
dauerhaft sein kann also dass unser
bewusstsein die bedingung der dauer ist
dann wäre dauer gar nicht so sehr der
gegenstand unseres bewusstseins die form
unseres bewusstseins müssen wir noch mal
ein bisschen offen lassen jedenfalls
hängt es mit unserem bewusstsein
zusammen und da darin zeigt sich das
werk sei durchaus ein bisschen in einer
idealistischen tradition steht
es ist nicht so dass die zeitdauer auf
uns von außen irgendwie ein rieselt dass
wir die zeitdauer sowie sie objektiv ist
der welt sehen die welt dauert nicht an
sich sind die welt dauer
nur bezogen auf uns auf unser bus sein
auch wenn wir natürlich gewisse
regelmäßige bewegung von außen haben
aber das sagt jetzt bergson dass die
nicht kontinuierlich sind die sind
diskontinuierlich und äußere dinge sind
immer für räumlich das problem ist diese
extremität die hat immer das problem des
räumlichen additiv indes nicht
verbindenden des getrennten und die
kontinuität das kontinuierliche dieses
staffelstab übergeben dieses verbinden
auch dieses erinnern sich an vergangene
moment das leistet nur unser bewusstsein
das ist so ganz allgemein die zugangs
weise und jetzt habe ich wie immer hier
noch heute diese leitfragen also was
bestimmt besser als das phänomen der
zeit aber wie bestimmte das dann wie
verhält sich berg songs theorie zur a
und b sei derzeit offensichtlich
vertritt er keine theorie der b3 das ist
klar so viel ist klar dass er natürlich
nicht hier sein ausgebreiteten
zeitstrahl hier denkt wo es hier nur
früher und später gibt und denkt auch
nicht so sehr glaube ich so eine eine
zeit im sinne dieser sei das eben auf
uns da etwas zukommt es hat schon diese
tendenz wird der art wie mir scheint
aber eher ich würde sagen er modifiziert
die haare noch ein ganzes stückchen und
zwar so dass er die arbeit nicht mehr in
einer reihe denken möchte also
horizontal möchte ihr das ganze also
eine art schicht verstehen als eine
schachtel um das hat er gesagt in einem
zitat platz eine ineinander stellung als
eine überlappung und als eine
antizipation eine als eine antizipation
ist das was vor uns liegt das
antizipieren wir im dauern denn erleben
und das was vergangen ist das erinnern
wir
es gibt ständig diese verbindungen von
dem was zukünftig ist und dem was
vergangen ist und deswegen trifft sonne
so eine horizontale linie eigentlich gar
nicht so gut das was er meint und da
können wir dann wieder dieses paradigma
von schelling benutzen der das natürlich
nur mit blick auf die vergangenheit
sagte sowie ein schichten modell was er
etwas ein vertikales das zeit wird diese
vertikal i tät bekommt und ich dass er
diese horizontal i tät zumal auch bei
der vorstellung einer horizontalen
zeitreihe jemand das problem ist dass
wir dazu neigen die zeit dadurch zufügt
räumlich zu vergeben ständen ich glaube
dass das ein bisschen das problem ist
wenn wir zeit zu sehr horizontal denken
denken wir zeit zu sehr im raum
und wenn wir zeit eher vertikal denken
denken wir zeit vielleicht ihr mehr
zeitgemäß das wird eine these mit denen
sie ihr in einer tiefen demission
natürlich ist auch die rede von der
tiefe wieder unsere verheimlichung aber
die rede von der tiefe von der
verschachtelung die verhindert dass wir
zeit auseinander dividieren und etwas
was eigentlich kontinuierlich ist in
diskontinuitäten auflösen deswegen
glaube ich dass er auch ihr so ein
vertikales modell bevorzugt aber wir
werden jetzt heute im zügigen durchgang
durch noch verbleibenden zitate die wir
uns das letzte mal ich auch schon
angesehen hatten noch mal diskutieren
und geben dann zentral wie verhalten
sich auch zeit nach bergs not zusammen
er kritisiert die verheimlichung derzeit
das ist so sein
topos und dann wollen wir auch noch mal
ganz am ende ich hoffe wir kommen da
noch hin schauen wie er kann kritisiert
als er sieht bei kant einen
grundsätzlichen fehler in seinem
zeitverständnis
soweit zu den fragen jetzt gehe ich
einfach ein bisschen schneller durch wir
hatten einige zitate hier schon ich
hatte auch in der zusammenfassung auf
einige hier schon war ich schon ein
bisschen näher eingegangen wir gehen
jetzt einfach ein bisschen zügiger durch
und ich versuche hier die wichtigsten
punkte hervor zu heben und dann können
wir darüber ein bisschen diskutieren als
ich lesen bevor wir drücken uns
notwendig durch worte aus und wir denken
fast immer räumlich mit anderen worten
die sprache zwingt uns unter unseren
vorstellungen dieselben schafen und
genauen unterscheidungen dieselben
diskontinuität herzustellen wie zwischen
den materiellen gegenständen ja das ist
also die eingangs kritik diskontinuität
dass gerade das was die dauer nicht ist
die dauer ist ihre kontinuität und im
raum wenn wir sagen hier steht ein stuhl
hier steht ein tisch dann haben wir die
diskontinuität der raum ist nicht so
beschaffen dass ein gegenstand in den
anderen übergeht
das sind substanzen das substanzielle
verständnis der raum ist geprägt durch
substanzen substanzen sind individuelle
dinge denn eine ganz klare außenseiter
haben und sich ganz klar von anderen
dingen unterscheiden lassen und es ist
dann die diskontinuität der eine
gegenstand fängt an und hörte auf und
dann beginnt der nächste aber sie gehen
nicht einander über sonst werden sie ihr
einen derselbe gegenstand und so ist es
in der räumlichen ordnung so ist aber
eben gerade nicht in der zeitlichen
orden und wir sind eben viel zu sehr in
unserem denken räumlich geprägt das sagt
dann auch jetzt in der zweiten hälfte
der heutigen sitzung marke heiliger das
ist auch dieses rohr in das er stößt
dieses horn stößt das ist auch ein
anliegen dass wir viel zu sehr räumlich
denken
und dann sagt er hier ist fällt uns
unglaublich schwer die dauer nur ihre
ursprüngliche reinheit vorzustellen das
ist klar
wir teilen wir neigen dazu die uhr in
gleiche parzellen zu teilen und in so
eine homogenität
also das ist hier unten die zeit in
homogene parzellen ein zurzeit das ist
auch so eine art von horizontalen
verheimlichung derzeit und dagegen
möchte argumentieren die zeit ist nach
berg so eben gerade nicht homogen dieser
weise also eben gleichmäßig getaktet
sondern gibt es durchaus erkennen
ja und jetzt sagt er hier und das ist
ebenso dieser diese schlüssel zum
verständnis man wird im äußersten fall
zu geben dass die vom bewusstsein
konzipierte per zitiert heißt einfach
war genommene wahrgenommen innere dauer
in der in einer darstellung der
bewusstseins vorgänge in der stufenweise
bereicherung dass dich auf gehe
und hier haben also diese
verschachtelung dieser stufenweise rufen
als eher vertikal geordnete das hatten
wir den letzten sitzung schon behandelt
jetzt geht es hier um das ziffernblatt
eine uhr die bewegung des zeigers und
die bewegung der schwingung des pendelns
und außerhalb von meinem bewusstsein
gibt es eigentlich immer nur eine
einzige lage des tigers und des pendels
wenn sie also einen schnitt machen das
bild anhalten in einem film dann sehen
sie eben zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
ich glaube hat auch irgendwas gegen das
verständnis von zeit als in durchaus
zeitpunkten bestehen wenn ich jetzt hier
ein pendel habe und dann habe ich eben
hier ein gewissen punkt markiert und
dann ist es eben hier und im nächsten
zeitpunkt ist es eben hier
wenn ich schaue und dann ist es eben
hier aber wenn ich das nur mir so
sequenz artig also nur so zeit mit art
ick dacht zeitpunkt artig dann bekomme
ich da keine dauern spielen habe ich nur
hier ein fixpunkt hier ein fixpunkt
ihren drei orte im raum die aufeinander
folgen aber die aufeinanderfolge diese
drei punkte im raum ist noch nicht die
dauer das macht noch nicht daraus dann
muss noch mehr dazu kommen dass ich hier
diesen prozess dieses panel bewegungs
dass die pendelbewegung als eine dauer
empfinden eine ausgedehnte dauert das
pendel schwingt und den ganzen prozess
der schwingung eine dauer empfinde das
pendel pendelt und jetzt sagt er hier es
ist der gegenseitige durchdringung
prozess der bewusstseins vorgänger der
die ware dauer ausmacht mit meinem
inneren falz und organisationsprozesse
also es ist nicht so dass wir einfach
nur jetzt dass eine wahrnehmen dann das
andere wahrnehmen als jetzt hier eben
das war das war ihm das wahrnehmen
sondern da passiert mit diesen
wahrnehmung in uns in unserem
bewusstsein selbst etwas die werden
organisiert und zwar nach einer
bestimmten logik tier so vertikal zu
denken ist das ist also jetzt hier so
die konnte jetzt hat er hier diese hacks
seriosität und die sukzession also die
extremität ist eben die äußerlichkeit
das ist das was wir konzipieren das was
eben im raum ist das ist aus und das
äußere sagt jetzt berg song hat
eigentlich keine sukzession kein
aufeinanderfolge das jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen schwierig zu verstehen war
eigentlich dieses pendel schon irgendwie
folgt aber dass ich eine folge damit ich
eine folge haben kann muss ich ja zwei
gegenstände mit zwei situationen
miteinander vergleichen ich muss ja
sagen wir hatten hier ihr sah
dank b und ganze und diese durchgang abc
der setzt voraus der sie mich erinnere
wenn ich bei ab in das bkh gefolgt ist
seit ich muss eine erinnerung von aaa
behalten und ohne das bewusstsein dass
ich habe ich keine erinnerung
es könnte sein dass es lebewesen gibt
die so unterschwellig seien jetzt mal
leben dass sie eben kein
erinnerungsvermögen haben das ist
durchaus möglich
die frage sondern erinnerungsvermögen
haben weiß ich nicht ameisen kann man
jedenfalls bestimmt nicht konditionieren
wir können uns noch kleinere tierchen
vorstellen mücken oder so eintagsfliegen
ob die eine erinnerung haben ich glaub's
nicht oder
oder gedeckten ist ja genau also dass
man irgendetwas fixieren kann und
vergleichen kann
hunde mit sicherheit und ich kann man
konditionieren konditionieren also durch
regelmäßigkeit in eine erwartungshaltung
bringen und diese erwartungshaltung sie
kennen alle den pawlowschen reflex der
funktioniert eben nur durch sowas wie
erinnerungen dass man etwas vergangenes
ins bewusstsein ruft und eine
erwartungshaltung daneben auch ausbildet
durch diese erinnerung
also das heißt für tiere gilt das
bestimmt auch das jetzt ganz interessant
wir reden hier nicht nur über menschen
und wir reden über zeit erfahrung
grundsätzlich und das könnte prinzipiell
auch wenn man nur von diesem bewusstsein
ausklingt auch bei tieren der fall sei
und dass tiere eben auch ein dauer
bewusstsein haben vielleicht nicht auf
diese hohen stufe aber auf einen
niederschwelligen stufe schon ja
ja also die extremität ist eben das was
im äußeren ist ne und reziprok ist
wechselweise also das heißt dass ich das
bewusstsein muss mit dem was außen vor
sich geht in ein wechselverhältnis
treten zum beispiel muss es diese
schwingung hier
diese pendelbewegung irgendwie
wahrnehmen und dann eben noch in sich
organisieren zu einer dauer erfahrung
und in unserem ich es eben nur die
sukzession angelegt wir haben in unserem
ich wieder begriff ja schon sagt nichts
äußeres und und im äußeren im raum
außerhalb des nicht das haben wir nur
eben diese äußerlichkeit aber nicht die
sukzession weil die gegenwärtige
schwingung von der nicht mehr
bestehenden vorhergegangenen radikal
unterschied ist sukzession slow sich
aber weil es sukzession nur für einen
bewussten beobachter geben kann der sich
das vergangene erinnert daran dass die
erinnerung und die zwei schwingungen
oder ihre symbole in einem aushilfs
halber vorgestellten raum nebeneinander
aufgereiht also genau genommen müssten
jetzt folgendes sagen die schwingung ist
jetzt eine schwingung
die frage ist weil man die stimmung sich
ganz durchführen lassen also die
schwingung sei jetzt mal die bewegung
von dort wieder zurück ist
oder würden sie das als zwei
schwingungen auf auffassen wie ist ihr
begriff gebrauch was in schwingung ist
eine schwingung nur in eine richtung
oder wieder zurück hin und zurück oder
dass eine ganze schon eine ganze
pendelbewegung dann wäre dieses diese
schlimme bewegung wäre dann a b c a b c
oder c b a wie auch im abc pa
das ist dann dieser weg ist dann die
bewegung des der schwingung und das wäre
dann als eine einheit aufgefasst und
unser bewusstsein damit es eine dauer
erfahrung hat würde dann eben diese
schwingung im raum ob er hatte weniger
nebeneinander stellen als es würde dann
so was wie eine abfolge es würde bei der
zweiten schwingung sich erinnern dass
schon eine schwingung gewesen ist würde
deswegen eine zweite davon unterscheiden
in erinnerung des bereits geschehen
all das ist das hier das es aus in einem
aushilfs halber vorgestellten raum
nebeneinander aufgereiht
also da findet dann doch wieder
seltsamerweise eine freundliche stadt
eine art austausch zwischen dem inneren
was nicht äußeres hat was die reine
sukzession hat und dem äußeren was auch
keine sonder da findet eine art
wechselwirkung stadt die endlose
irgendwas muss es einen stoffaustausch
das ist jetzt alles noch sehr abstrakt
wir lesen einfach mal weiter da die zu
passiven phasen unseres bewussten lebens
die sich indessen gegenseitig
durchdringen jede für sich genommen
einen simultanen händel schwingungen
entsprechende andererseits diese
schwingungen deutlich voneinander
unterschieden sind insofern die eine
nicht mehr ist wenn die antritt gewöhnen
wir uns darin zwischen den sukzessiven
momenten und des bewussten lebens
dieselbe unterscheidung aufzustellen die
pendel schwingungen lösen ist sozusagen
ineinander äußerliche teile auf hieraus
entspringt denn die irrtümliche
vorstellung einer inneren homogenen dem
raum analogen dauer deren identische
momente aufeinanderfolgen ohne einander
zu durchdringen
andererseits profitieren gewissermaßen
die pendel schwingungen die nur deshalb
wohl unterschiede sind weil die eine
verschwunden ist wenn die andere
auftritt durch den einfluss den sie in
der geschilderten weise auf unser
bewusstes leben ausgeübt haben
also er kritisiert jetzt die auffassung
dass die innere zeitdauer dass die
homogen sei also gleichartig sein wie
das äußere was in gleichartige portion
zu teilen ist das ist das was sie
kritisieren also wir dürfen jetzt nicht
unsere innere zeitdauer unserer zeit
darüber bewusst sein analog zum raum
verstehen dass der raum die pendel
schwingungen hatte hat eine auslenkung
die ist genau definiert
sie hatten eine genaue und genaue ausmaß
und wir dürfen zeigt er jetzt nicht
unser innenleben unserer inneres zeit
bewusst sein analog zu diesen äußeren
portioniert halten verstehen die jetzt
definiert sind durch die auslenkung zum
beispiel des pendels
was der homogen und gleichartig er sagt
das innere dieses innere zeitempfinden
ist inhomogen was auch immer das jetzt
will ich es mal weiter dank der
erinnerung die unser bewusstsein von
ihnen ganzen organisiert hat werden sie
aufbewahrt und dann aneinander gereiht
kurz wir erschaffen für sie eine vierte
raum dimension die wir die homogene zeit
nennen und die es möglich macht das die
pendelbewegung obwohl sie sich
eigentlich fortschritts los vollzieht
sich ins unbegrenzte an sich selber an
wright das ist dass wir haben eine
pendelt schwingung wollte und dann kommt
die nächste
aber eigentlich ist es ja dieselbe
pendelt schon aber wir tun so als gäbe
es hier die nächste das ist praktisch
die erste ist die zweite und dann gibt's
die dritte hat dazu vor
und dass wir das so einander reihen
können das ist das was er sagt dass wir
das einen raum erschaffen indem wir
diese bewegung aufreihen
das ist es seine these
nein
versuchen wir nun in diesem sehr
komplexen prozess den anteil des
wirklich und es aus der einbildung
standen genau zu bestimmen
so finden wir folgendes es gibt einen
realen raum ohne dauer
wo aber phänomene simultan mit unseren
bewusstseinszustände auftreten und
verschwinden es gibt eine wirkliche
dauert deren heterogene momente sich
gegenseitig durchdringen wurde aber
jeder moment in einem zustand der
äußeren welt der zur selben zeit mit im
auftritt angenähert werden kann von den
anderen momenten eben durch diese
annäherung abgetrennt werden kann
aus der vergleichen dieser beiden
realitäten steht eine dem raume ins
lehnte symbolische vorstellung von der
dauer diesen im zoo die illusorische
form eines homogenen mediums an und das
verbindende zwischen diesen beiden
terminen im raume und der dauer ist die
simultan i tät die man als den
schnittpunkt derzeit mit dem raum
definieren könnte oder es ist jetzt ein
sehr kompliziertes zitat sind sie da ein
bisschen schlau geworden wie können wir
jetzt dass wir uns versuchen
vorzustellen
amazon ideen
das ist jetzt typisch typisches phänomen
logan gerede als wir das nicht abwertend
aber so reden phänomenologie oder
schreiben von analog es ist sehr
kompliziert auch sehr metaphorisch haben
sie eine idee wie können wir uns jetzt
diese die tat hier annähern
wer fragen zum beispiel zum pr-manager
in der ersten einheit gefühle für den
dauer die vorstellungen dabei dann
entschieden
gea
dieser raum entsteht dadurch dass wir
diese homogenen erfahrung
aneinanderreihen
und das ist dann homogen und er sagt
aber zu diesem homogenen raum dass das
nicht die eigentliche dauer ist das ist
so eine art symbolische vorstellung von
der dauer das meinte damit also wir für
räumlichen die zeit indem wir eben diese
sequenzen aneinanderreihen das additiv
das ist etwas räumliches wir
verheimlichen die zeit und indem wir die
zeit für räumlichen symbolisieren wir
die zeit im raum
also wir versuchen uns diese
inhomogenität derzeit die zeit ist
diffus die zeit ist nicht portioniert in
uns sagt er die ist ich glaube dass er
da an solchen intuition anruft wie dass
wir eben zeit erfahrungen haben wo es
etwas länger dauert also wirklich dieses
alltägliche gerede von eine sekunde oder
zwei sekunden war für mich wie eine
halbe stunde oder viña oder sowas sollte
dies wirklich jetzt wird nicht genommen
eine rede die wir ursprünglich ja gar
nicht jetzt in den philosophischen
diskurs sie aufnehmen wollten weil wir
sagen das ist noch eine subjektive zeit
erfahren aber ich glaube das meint er
wird diese ahlers objektivste zeit
erfahrungen die es gibt das eine sekunde
die jetzt objektiv so gemessen ist für
mich für ein ökologisch betrachtet den
wert von 5 minuten
das meint er mit der inhomogenen zeit
inhomogen dass die zeit nicht gleich
getaktet ist dass wir in bestimmten
phasen zeit länger erleben das ist für
ihn jetzt im gegensatz zu den anderen
philosophen die wir bisher gelesen
hatten
das eigentliche der zeit als das
eigentliche derzeit ist ihre
subjektivität ihre subjektive qualität
dass es sich ganz verschieden ausdehnen
kann in unserem empfinden als er nimmt
unsere subjektivität als phänomenologie
am aller ernstesten und demgegenüber
muss für berg so alles andere
nur als eine abstraktion unser unserer
unmittelbaren zeit erfahrung gelten
das ist also der punkt und die meisten
der bisher behandelten philosophen
sagten es gerade anders und sagt nein
das ist ja eine abstraktion oder anders
gesagt das ist ja so eine seine
subjektivität von der müssen wir
abstrahieren
wir müssen hin zu den objektiven zeit
kommen also wir müssen wegkommen von
diesem beliebigen im inhomogen zeit
auslösen eine homogene zeit aber haben
die gleich getaktet zeit sie juden aber
auch letztendlich immanuel kant und ich
würde sagen selbst augustinus mit der
ara derzeit möchte natürlich durchaus
auch seine gleich schwebende gleich
temperierte zeit haben nur eben unter
dem jeweiligen vorzeichen der der
subjektiv erfahrbaren gegenwart und
vergangenheit zu sagen nein wir müssen
die alles subjektiv zeit erfahrung an
die einen anfang stellen und alles
andere sieht davon nur ab weil es eben
die zeit immer mehr verheimlicht das ist
ja der punkt also das ist praktisch da
nimmt sie die illusorische form die
zeitdauer die alles objektivste zeit
dauern die illusorische form eines
homogenen mediums an das ist der raum
eines kontinuierlichen und das
verbindende zwischen diesen beiden
terminen im raume unter dauer ist die
simultan i tät gleichzeitigkeit die man
als den schnittpunkt derzeit mit dem
raum definieren
das symbolische ist die verheimlichung
derzeit so wissen wir jetzt schon
als es vollzieht sich etwas simultan so
lese ich das jetzt im uns und auch außer
uns wir nehmen eine bewegung außer uns
innerlich war und verfolgen diese in
ihrer dauerhaftigkeit
wir bringen das zusammen das war sehr
enders mose genannt hat im vorherigen
zitat im vorhofohr vorherigen zitat
diese endlose diese gegenseitige
durchdringung prozess von inneren
äußeren das bezieht er jetzt auch auf
den raum die raum bewegung und das
innere als wir machen das innere zum
äußeren wir zitieren diese diese
schwulenbewegung wir verleihen aber auch
dem äußeren erst seine sukzessive und
dieser wechselprozess das scheint er
dann auch als ein schnittpunkt zu
bezeichnen ja also sehr kompliziert die
ganz reine dauer ist die form die die
sukzession unserer bewusstseins
vorgänger annimmt wenn es sich dessen
enthält zwischen dem gegenwärtigen um
den vorhergehenden zuständen eine
scheidung zu vollziehen
dazu hat es keineswegs nötig sich an die
vorübergehende empfindungen oder
vorstellung ganz und gar zu verlieren
denn dann wird es ja im gegenteil zu
dauern aufhören also wenn man sich zu
sehr in eine empfindung hinein vertieft
und die fixiert die empfindung ebenso
wenig braucht es die vorangegangenen
zustände zu vergessen es genügt wenn es
diese zustände in dem es sich ihre
erinnert nicht neben den aktuellen
zustand wie einen punkt neben einen
anderen punkt stellt sind dass es sie
mit ihm organisiert wie es geschieht
wenn wir uns die töne einer melodie die
sozusagen miteinander verschmelzen ins
gedächtnis rufen
könnte man nicht sagen dass wenn diese
töne auch aufeinander folgen
wie sieht ihr noch ineinander appell
zitieren und dass sie als ganzes einem
lebewesen vergleichbar sind dessen teile
wenn sie auch unterschiedlich sind sich
trotzdem gerade durch ihre solidarität
gegenseitig durchdringen
der beweis dafür ist dass wenn wir den
takt unterbrechen indem wir einen ton
der melodie über gebühr aushalten nicht
übertriebene länge als solche sondern
die qualitative veränderung die damit
dem ganzen des musikalischen satzes
wieder fährt uns unser verhalten
bemerkbar macht das ist jetzt eine ganz
typische phänomenologische beschreibung
ja wir nehmen einen bereich zum beispiel
aus der kunst kann auch mit der malerei
machen jetzt hier ist die tonkunst und
wir demonstrieren anhand eines
künstlerischen phänomens die theorie die
wir da phänologische arbeitet habe ich
halte dieses zitat für das wichtigste
des ganzen textes war hier die
wichtigsten begriffe zusammen in
erscheinung treten können wir das noch
mal zusammen uns versuchen zu erarbeiten
also es geht jetzt hier um die
antizipation und um die erinnerung
wir sehen auch so ein bisschen kalt hier
so schlecht geheizt muss man den mantel
anziehen
also wie würden sie das jetzt verstehen
also entscheidend ist hier ja
das was
sind es wieder verändert
ich glaube dass ein guter punkt also
dass die miteinander verschmelzen
also es ist nicht so dass wir sie nicht
mehr also wir sollten sie nicht
nebeneinander stellen also nicht sollen
wir das neue einfach punktuell
aneinander reihen sondern es ist eher so
dass dann noch was drauf gesetzt wird
aber das untere dann zugleich verändert
zb wenn sie jetzt eine musik ein
musikalisches stück hören und es kommt
jetzt ein ton den sie nicht erwarten
dann wird das vorhergehende an das sich
jeder nun auch in einem anderen licht
erscheinen und um stimmen
das hat so eine rückwirkung als
organisch alles hängt miteinander
zusammen
im jeweiligen zeitpunkt könnte man sagen
sind die vorherigen zeitpunkt mit sage
jetzt nicht eingeschlossen aber mit
betroffen sind sie deswegen hat es die
dauer paradoxerweise die dimension der
gleichzeitigkeit auch das simultan i tät
also es ist so in der dauer das etwas
späteres das frühere irgendwie noch
berührt sag ich mal
also mit ihm zusammen hängt und das
früher nicht nicht einfach nur losgelöst
jetzt vorbei ist in der vergangenheit
verschwunden dass das vergangene hat
eine präsenz in der im gegenwärtigen
verschmelzen sie
und jetzt ist es entscheidende könnte
man nicht sagen dass wenn diese töne
auch aufeinander folgen aufeinander
folgen ist hier eigentlich diese
linearität sukzessive verheimlichung
dass wenn sie aufeinander folgen wie es
sie dennoch in einander ab herr zitieren
dass die verschachtelung wir haben sie
vertikal präsent und dass sie es als
ganzes mit einem lebewesen vergleichbar
sind dessen teile wenn sie auch
unterschieden sind sich dennoch gerade
durch ihre solidarität gegenseitig
durchdringen als solistisches phänomen
ein ganzheitliches phänomene wo alles in
einer zusammenhängt und jetzt das letzte
beispiel ist indes klar geworden hier
dieses dieser dieser beweist in edelster
bringt mit einem ton also stell dich mal
eine beliebige motiv vor
und wenn sie jetzt einen beliebigen ton
einfach zu lange aushalten dass dann das
vorhergehende in einem neuen licht
erscheinen
und das zeigt dass es so ein vertikales
modell ist weil das vorhergehende
dadurch auch tangiert wird das aktuelle
dass es hat so eine rückstrahlung der
phänomenologie nennt das auch retention
dass die rückstrahler und die potenzial
das die vor strahlung die erwartungen
sind diese richtung geht das
ja das ist so die theorie
finden sie die überzeugt wie sehen sie
das
würde ihnen das 1
als es etwas ineinander geschüttelt ist
und auch wenn sie sich mal überlegen sie
haben ein musikstück gehört und sie
haben es ja häufig gehört daneben sieht
das musikstück da nicht mehr so aktiv
war
jetzt kommt dieser ton kommt dieser ton
sind sie sehen dann immer zusammenhält
sagt okay jetzt beginnt ein neuer satz
aber dieser satz verweist auf den
vorhergehenden oder der satz wird vom
vorhergehenden zb hat von ihnen jemanden
musik studiert oder sie müssen wir jetzt
widersprechen wenn ich jetzt was
falsches sagen aber zum beispiel eine
kadenz bevor die kadenz beginnt geht
einsatz zu ende
etwas was vor der kadenz war die kadenz
kommt heißt es zum schluss zb in mozarts
klavierkonzerten da müsse die aller
tollsten kadenzen ja meint er immer
wieder neu dafür das ist typisch mozart
gibt's natürlich auch waffen und bevor
die kadenz einsetzt ich habe ich das
dann immer mehr erklärt gibt es eine art
doppel punkt und dann kommt die kadenz
die kadenz ist eine art
er hat antwort aber die beginnt nochmal
ganz die beginnt eigentlich so dass ich
gar nicht richtig an schließt an das
feuer geht also ganz interessantes
phänomen jedenfalls verstehen sie die
kadenz nicht einfach nur als etwas was
darauf folgt auf den früheren gegensatz
sondern sie verstehen die kadenz als
eine antwort auf das was in einer
anderen logik
sie verstehen eigentlich in der musik
aufeinander folgen von tönen oder ton
komplexen nicht mehr nur additiv
sukzessiv logisch letztendlich das ist
jetzt die antwort dass der doppelpunkt
so und diese dieses logische verständnis
ist eben gerade kein additives
verstellen sondern es ist eher so ein
begründung das verhältnis oder wie auch
immer aber in begründung verhältnis ist
zum beispiel jetzt nicht nur zeitlich
aktiv oder aufeinanderfolgen zu
verstehen in der folge eine folgerung
geht auch nicht im bloßen nacheinander
auf da kommt noch mehr mittel spielen
das wollte ich jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen illustrieren also es gibt eine
andere logik letztendlich und sind nicht
nicht es nicht mehr nur die logik des
bloßen aufeinanderfolgenden es ist immer
noch durch anders motiviert und das
vorhergehende hat immer noch eine
relevanz wird es vorher gehen dass
nachfolgen es ist immer noch stärker
miteinander verbunden und ich meine
komposition sagt es doch schon die
komposition ist eine organisation von
tonmaterial über die zeit hinweg kommen
natürlich ganz andere strukturen noch
mitgespielt haben also ich glaube das
hat das schon sehr zu recht auf die
musik gezielt in der musik wahrnehmung
nehmen wir eben nicht so war das wie
eins nach dem anderen setzen sondern wir
nehmen es eher in so einer schachtel
oder
naja damit wenn sie spielen wollen
müssten sie also die vorstellung
schwarzen augen wenn sie zum beispiel
neue ich kann das erste moderne spielen
können
da müssen sie einen körpers aber es ist
also ein überhang und bis das problem
derzeit weilen
[Musik]
es gibt natürlich die möglichkeit dass
selbst wenn man ein stück zum ersten mal
hört sie haben gehört wie der mitte
ungefähr man hat schon was gehört vom
stück sitzen der mitte und plötzlich hat
man das gefühl diese stelle die passt
nicht aus dem was davor kam das ist ja
durchaus auch möglich in wirklichen
kompositionen dass der komponist die
komponistin so was beabsichtigt dass
jetzt diese stelle einfach nicht passt
das könnte ja auch sagen das ist
durchaus möglich aber dann ist dieser
effekt eben gewollt sage ich mal nah
dann ist er eben ist der effekt eben
intendiert dann wird bewusst mit dieser
zeit empfinden gespielt aber aus dem was
vorher folgte können wir schon uns eine
erwartungshaltung aufbauen jetzt
wirklich dessen was noch kommen kann
in der regel können wir wenn wir die
hälfte eines stückes gehört haben
aufgrund der organischen struktur und
ich direkt erschließen was nachkommt
aber wir wissen wo es lang geht und wenn
dann irgendwie was kommt was das stört
merck wieder sofort
das heißt derzeit genauso
ja wir sind gute frage wollten sie
gerade sich dazu melden
das gibt es heute und dann setzt nochmal
an oder macht noch einen kleinen
schlenker
ja also mit der erwartung ich bin schon
das teilweise wirklich mit der zeit
vorstellen zu vergleichen ist weil dann
hilft der markterwartung von vergangen
gegenwert
als jetzt könnte man sich überlegen ein
guter hinweis ich weiß nicht ob man das
jetzt mit der pendel schwingung man wenn
man es auf herunterbricht könnte man
sagen jede komposition hat mit
grundschwingung also sei es jetzt die
tonart oder wie auch immer die tonart zu
der es alles hin treten
sie beginnt mit der tonart und sie endet
in der tonart dazwischen kann es dann
modulation geben oder ein tonwechsel das
ist ja alles wirklich und zb kann es
dann sein dass sie plötzlich im stück
drin plötzlich merken hoppla andere
tonart ja passt jetzt irgendwie nicht
und dann ziehen sie am irritiert und
dann wird das ganze aber am ende
aufgelöst und wissen sie wie das eine
runde sache
und jetzt kann man sich überlegen wie
kann man das mit einer pendelbewegung
deshalb auch ihr punkt oder wie kann man
das mit seiner band in schwingung
zusammenbringt ich meine man muss dann
eben sagen so ein ganzes stück eine
ganze komposition ist eine pendelt
schwingung eine große pendelt stimmung
und wenn wir jetzt aber natürlich eine
pendelt schwingung hören nicht hören
sehen
dann haben wir darin keine erfahrung der
störung höher ist und pendelt ist
einfach gleich geschwungen und beine
musste bei einer komposition ist es
nicht zu rollen aber auch ich würde
sagen selbst so eine simple pendelt
schwingung hat eine organisation zb eben
dass sie dann wenn wir es eben in die
zeit da nehmen dass wir dann diese
sinuskurve haben hier und zb
er ist es ja schon seltsam einer pendel
schwingt da sie zb sowas hat und dass
sie hier die größte steigung handels
dass es hier also maximal gibt und hier
immer die ableitung nehmen das dann eben
hier die steigung am größten ist als
seine vermeintlich banale schwingung
hatten sich schon momente die aufregend
sind sage ich jetzt mal so und es wird
mir nicht ganz gelingen so ein komplexes
stück mit seiner pendelt schwingung
zusammenzubringen
aber es ist so auch eine vermeintlich
banale pendelt schwingung hat wenn wir
sie in der zeit sehen eine struktur den
interessanter ist wo es besonders
merkwürdige punkte gibt nämlich den
punkt dem punkt an dem punkt mindestens
ich weiß nicht ob es sie haben insofern
kann das nicht eins zu eins analog sehen
es geht ja aber ich glaube ich muss mal
wieder helfen
achtung ich hoffe die türe bedeckt
jedenfalls jetzt mal wieder bezogen auf
das pendel also gerade das wird so eine
sinuskurve daraus machen zeigt dass wir
das ganze organisieren
schauen sie mal von von so einer
primitiven bewegungen hier oder so drei
punkte hier kommen wir zur so eine
sinuskurve wenn wir jetzt die dauer
ausbreiten wenn wir es freut mich ja da
ist schon einiges gewonnen würde ich
sagen aber natürlich soll musikstück ist
schon man kann auch sagen so ein pendel
schwingung ist eben die ganz primitive
erfahrung von dauer
das sind bestimmte momente schon
angelegt und eine komposition oder eine
melodie zu hören sind eben besonders
hochstufige phänomene von dauern
anders ausgedrückt und könnte sagen da
wo eine pendelbewegung ist daher
vielleicht nur so zwei stufen nämlich
das links rechts oder vielleicht noch
das mittel seien drei stufen
wenn wir das pendel in der mitte
wahrnehmung der innern wir uns an die
eine auslenkung und wir antizipieren die
nächste ausgekommen haben wir also hier
sind in der mitte haben wir hier diese
beiden richtungen das heißt wir hätten
hier vielleicht drei stufen muss jetzt
nicht kann jetzt auch so gestuft sein
muss ja gleichartig sein
wie auch immer und wenn wir jetzt aber
melodien haben kommen noch völlig andere
stufe mit mit hinzu das heißt die
pendler schwingung des soll
grundrhythmus jede melodie hatten
grundrhythmus intakten taktschlag das
ist nicht das wären 1 einzel takt
vielleicht ja oder wie auch immer so ein
großer sehr primitive primitive taktung
primitiv jetzt sind es passen wenn sie
damals 78 haben ja
oder 39 takt haben ja da wird oder oder
dann 68 78 in dieser folge her gibt es
ja alles oder 13 16 oder sowas takt dann
wird es plötzlich ganz ganz kompliziert
wir haben sie ganz verschiedene
schwingungen miteinander und dann ist
eben das los eine grundform ist eine
ganz ganz banale grundform technologie
kann sich durch ganz verschiedene
antritt dauerhaftigkeit und taktungen
auszeichnen ja also das war jetzt mal
ein kleiner exkurs aber ich gebe dir
recht da kann man muss nur weiter fragen
ist diese analogie ergibt sich nicht
unmittelbar
ja aber ich finde es trotzdem ein sehr
plastisches beispiel was er hier bringt
weiter sagte die sozio lässt sich also
ohne die wohn unterschieden haid und wie
eine gegenseitige durchdringung eine
solidarität eine intime organisation von
elementen begreifen deren jede das ganze
vertritt und von diesem nur durch ein
abstraktion spheres denken zu
unterscheiden und soll ihren ist eine
solche vorstellung von der dauer würde
sich ohne allen zweifel ein wesen machen
das zugleich identisch und veränderlich
wäre und dem die idee des raumes
gänzlich gehalt wir aber sind mit dieser
idee vertraut stehen sogar in ihrem
panne und tragen sie unbewusst in unsere
vorstellung von der reinen sukzession
hinein
wir stellen unsere wurst science
vorgehen ist so nebenan
das ist die analogie zu bauen dass wir
sie simultan abwehr zitieren und zwar
nicht ineinander sondern nebeneinander
kurz wir projizieren die zeit in den
raum drücken die dauer durch
ausgedehntes aus so lang war die zeit zu
kurz masse und die sukzession nimmt für
uns die form einer stetigen linie oder
kette an deren teile sich grün rühren
ohne sich zu durchdringen
beachten wir hierbei dass dieses letzte
bild nicht mehr die sukzessive sondern
die simultane rezeption des vor und
einschließt und das ist ein widerspruch
bedeutet eine sukzession anzunehmen die
nur sukzession will und trotzdem in
einem und demselben augenblick ganz
vorhanden sein könnte wieder sehr viele
neue begriffe worauf es jetzt ankommt
ist dass das er von einer gegenseitigen
durchdringung also sowohl unterschieden
halt ohne wohl unterschieden heißt
wohn und verschiedenheit wäre die
kontinente kontinuität dagegen wie eine
gegenseitige durchdringung eine
solidarität und jetzt kommt eine intime
organisation von elementen deren jede da
jedes das ganze vertritt als wir haben
in jedem moment eigentlich dass ganz
enthalten das sagen auch viele musiker
dass wir oder komponisten zu sagen in
diesem motiv in diesem dreiklang und in
diesem akkord haben wir das ganze stück
total warum weil es eben dieselbe tonart
bis zum beispiel wenn ich jetzt eben
einen akkord zentral bringe der genau
dieser tonart ist und kann ich eben da
irgendwie schon ablesen dass das ganze
darin enthalten ist er irgendwie das
ganze ausdrücken verlangen
wir kommen eben nur durch eine
abstraktion spheres denkt als wie raps
trainieren nur davon indem er es geben
dann in wohlproportionierte teile
unterscheiden das heißt und ersetzt die
der clou die abstraktion findet statt
von dem vertical organisch geschichteten
aller subjektiv ssten zeitdauer
empfinden hin zu diesem horizontal
modell hinter dieser gleich getaktete
zeit
das ist alle die kritik er sagt jeder
der sich zurzeit räumlich vorstellt
abstrahiert vom eigentlich bezahlt hat
die ganze tradition könnte eher sagen
auch cantus vki hat nur ein abstraktes
verständnis wird sein und kein
eigentliches verstehen dass das
eigentliche verständnis der zeit ist
immer vertikal vorzustellen
als objektiv c't und das ist eben nicht
schlecht häufig würde man sagen ja gut
aber das doch nicht objekt wir brauchen
durch ein objektiv behilft von zeit und
würde es sagen nein zeitdauer ist nicht
objektiv dennoch können wir objektiv
über die zeit der reden also wir können
auch objektiv über subjektivität reden
das ist gar kein problem
ja ich indem ich eben beispiele bringe
wie sich das manifestiert das ist
natürlich auch wieder objektiv dann
natürlich ist es für jeden anders aber
in dem für jeden anders sein können wir
uns darüber wieder für gegenständlichen
auf einer abstrakten geben nachdem
verstrichen
wenn wir eben solche begriffe wie
organisation und verwenden objektivieren
wir ja die alle subjektiv sste zeit
darin finden spricht man nun von einer
sukzession ordnung in der dauer und von
der umkehr barkeit dieser ordnung ist
dann die fragliche sukzession die reine
sukzession wie wir sie oben definierten
die mit ausdehnungen nicht nicht ist
oder die sukzession die sich im raum
auseinander faltet der gestellt dass man
davon gleichzeitig mehrere getrennte und
nebeneinander angeordnete termini kommen
schon fassen kann
die antwort wird nicht zweifelhaft sein
zwischen termini ist eine ordnung nicht
ohne ihre vorherige unterscheidung zu
ermöglichen und hohen nachträgliche
vergleichen der stellen die sie
einnehmen mann ab er zitiert sie also
als vielfach simultan und wohl
unterschieden mit einem wort man reiht
sie nebenan darauf wenn man als im
sukzessiven eine ordnung einführte wird
eben damit die sukzession so simultan i
tät und projiziert sich den raum kurz
wenn die verschiebung eines fingers auf
einer fläche oder linie mir eine reihe
von empfindungen verschiedener
qualitäten verschafft es wird von den
zwei dingen 1 1 treten entweder ich
werde mit diese empfindungen
in der dauer vorstellen oder sie werden
dann zu aufeinanderfolgen dass ich mir
in einem gegebenen augenblick nicht
mehrere von ihnen als simultan und
dennoch so unterschieden vorzustellen
vermag oder aber ich werde eine
subventions ordnung heraus erkennen und
dann habe ich nicht nur die fähigkeit
eine situation von termini wahrzunehmen
sondern obendrein diese nebeneinander
aufzureihen nachdem ich sie
unterschieden haben mit einem wort ich
habe dann bereits die raumvorstellung
die vorstellung von einer in der dauer
umkehrbare rey oder auch nur einer
gewissen ordnung der sukzession in der
zeit enthält also ihrerseits schon die
forschung des raumes und eignet sich
nicht dazu ihn zu definieren
also hier ist jetzt geben das problem
der ordnung der zeitdauer die eben immer
schon die raum projektion impliziert
dass geordnet und spreche dann versuche
ich gerade kontinuitäten
diskontinuitäten herzustellen
das separieren brauche es darauf nicht
weiter mehr einzugehen
das vielleicht noch kurz die sukzession
lässt sich also ohne die wo
unterschieden haid und wie eine
gegenseitige durchdringung eines
solidarität eine intim organisation muss
es heißen von elementen begreifen
deren jede das ganze vertritt genau das
hatten wir schon im letzten ca
was ist die dauer in uns eine
qualitative mannigfaltigkeit die mit der
zahl keine ähnlichkeit hat eine
organische entwicklung die der jedoch
keine wachsende quantität ist eine reine
heterogenität innerhalb derer es keine
unterschiedenen qualitäten gibt kurz die
momente der landauer sind nicht einander
äußerlich das meint diese ineinander
schachteln wenn ich jetzt hier einen
projektor habe und hier ein pult dann
sind diese zwei gegenstände einander
äußerlich wir sind klar voneinander
unterschieden als substanzen sind sich
gegner entgegen äußerlich und in der
inneren dauer eben nicht also dass es
auch immer in einer entwicklung also das
vorhergehende treibt das folgende hervor
sie denken ja auch immer wenn sie jetzt
ein pendel ziehen
das b ist folgt auf aber so dass
irgendwie außer hervorgeht
[Musik]
so in zwei minuten geht die bombe hoch
habe ich ein falsches wort gesagt
draußen so jetzt ist gut
also jetzt haben sie auch eine erfahrung
von zeitdauer gehabt also das treibt
auseinander hervor
also dann betreibt außer hervor sich
wird außer hervorgetreten was sind
zustanden werden
und das habe natürlich diese organische
strukturiertheit haben wir natürlich am
meisten bei der musik das ist ganz klar
bei der tonkunst und jetzt kommen wir
hier noch kurz auf ganz irrtum zu
sprechen kann es wird schon bestand nach
bergs und darin dass er die zeit als ein
homogenes medium auf fasste er kann
scheint nicht bemerkt zu haben dass sich
die wirkliche dauer aus momenten
zusammensetzt die einander innerlich
sind und dass wenn sie die gestalt eines
homogenen ganzen annimmt die zeit sie
sich eben damit im raume ausdruck so
läuft gerade die unterscheidung die
erkannt zwischen raum und zeit auf
stellt im grunde darauf hinaus die zeit
mit dem raume und die symbolische
repräsentation des ich mit dem ich
selbst zu verwechseln symbolischer
vorstellung war zeit so freue mich
erkannt hielt das bewusstsein für
unfähig die psychischen tatsachen anders
als in der nebeneinander reihung
wahrzunehmen und vergesst aber dass ein
medium in dem diese tatsachen sich
nebeneinander reihen und voneinander
unterschieden unterscheiden notwendig
raum und nicht mehr dauern ist also
können sie nochmal kurz selbst in
eigenen worten haare wogen jetzt nach
bergs der fehler von kant stand
nein
wo bleibt kant stehen
das zeigt es kommt ja
richtig also es geht in die richtige
richtung aber er hat noch einen weiteren
kritikpunkt ja genau
als berg so wirft kan vor durch die
reine anschauungs form ist die form des
raumes unter zeit letztendlich die zeit
zu homogenisieren all dem kann sagt es
ist so eine art im raster was wir über
die welt legen oder mitbringen die zeit
müssen form dadurch vereinigt er
letztendlich die zeit
und zwar weil weil jedem nach kant durch
die anschauungs form zeit nur sukzessiv
im sinne der nebeneinander reihung
wahrnehmbar ist sagt jetzt mehr gesorgt
das stimmt müssen uns fragen aber es hat
was davon weil bekannt denkt die reine
anschauen es kommt derzeit so das wird
dadurch erst arithmetisch operieren
können und das denkt sich kann so dass
wir eine reihe r spricht wirklich von
einer reihe kann spricht von einer
zeitreihe müsste man noch mal genauer
müssen sie noch mal kurz in den text
schauen denn wir hatten bei kant aber
ich meine mich zu erinnern dass er von
einer rein spricht wie ryan dunn in der
zeitreihen wir etwas auf das ist also
diese zeit linie in der wir etwas
aufbauen können das ist die reine
anschauungs form derzeit die auf raiba
kite die bedingung der möglichkeit des
auseinander ryans und damit hat
natürlich wechseln schon recht das kann
dir die zeit insofern sie aufeinander
gereiht werden kann
eine gewisse analogie zum raum hat kant
denkt die zeit nicht so dass wir hier
schichtungen haben das simultan simultan
und organisch oder so
das denkt ihr ist kelly als wir sind
praktisch wir haben hier so einen
übergang der von kant über schelling
hinzu berg songs sich vollzieht ob jetzt
bergson schelling rezipiert hat weiß ich
nicht muss ich mal nachschauen aber die
entwicklungsrichtung ist doch ziemlich
eindeutig es geht hier weg von diesem
räumlichen vorstellen von zeit von einem
horizontal verstimmt bis hin zu einem
vertikal zeitverständnis und das scheint
da scheint jetzt hier berg soll eine
tendenz bei schelling noch weiter zu
treiben die aber eben sich auch gegen
kant jeweils richtet also erkannt
sondern hat abstoß punkten
obwohl kannte die zeit sehr subjektiv
sieht also jetzt nicht im sinne dieser
zeit dauer aber eben als bedingung der
möglichkeit württemberg songs sagen
lieber kant lieber großer philosoph aus
königsberg du hast zeit noch nicht
subjektiv genug dass du bist immer noch
viel zu objektiv oder räumlich dieses
orientalen modells derzeit ja also
bekannt ist seit nur nebeneinander rey
und eben nicht ineinander stellung wie
es gerne hätte
dadurch kam er kann zudem ein und das
sich in den tiefen des bewusstseins
dieselbe zustände ebenso wiederholen
könnten wie sich dieselben physischen
phänomene im raume wiederholen
wenigstens gestand er dies implizite zu
wenn er der qualitäts beziehung in der
inneren welt denselben sinn und dieselbe
rolle bei mars wie in der äußeren welt
damit wartet dann die freiheit eine
unbegreifliche tatsache und trotzdem
erwarte er sich infolge eines
unbegrenzten der unbewussten vertrauens
in jene innere abwärts aktion deren
tragweite einzuschränken bestrebt war
einen unerschütterlichen glauben an die
freiheit
so erhob er sie zur höhe der nominal und
da er die dauer mit dem raume vermengt
hatte macht er aus jenem wirklichen und
freien ich das tatsächlich dem raume
fremden einig dass in gleicher weise
auch der dauer gegenüber äußerlich oder
infolgedessen unseren erkenntnissen
mögen nun zugänglich sein sollte als
eine eigentlich ziemlich ständige kritik
und jetzt
der beamer auch nicht mehr so ganz geld
das war der grund der beamer hat sehen
sie es gibt eine verschiebung sehen sie
hier
hier eine violett verschiebung ob das
auch der beamer zurückzuführen ich weiß
nicht ob der ton kam er von hier oben
von weiter hier wie auch immer
jedenfalls ist diese kritik an kant
ziemlich scharfsinnig weil das eine
immanente kritik ist wissen sie was der
unterschied zwischen einer immanenten
einen externen kritik ist das ist eine
immanente kritik mal hin
man nennt die kritik immer mehr kritik
heißt wissen sie es wie kritisierte den
kannte sagt erkannt du hast du einen
wichtigen theorie bestandteil übersehen
oder wie macht ihr das jetzt
genau also das ist auch diese immanente
kritik er begibt sich in seine theorie
hinein und sagt dann kann austeilen
prämissen aus seiner theorie ergibt sich
folgende konsequenz aus seiner theorie
ergibt sich dass zeit räumlich gedacht
wird und diese konsequenz ist nicht
akzeptabel und deswegen muss neben im
umkehrschluss diese theorie eigentlich
falsch sein als er folgt kann bis ins
letzte er akzeptiert seine prämissen
erstmals seine türen und buchstabiert
sie weiter aus er sagt aber daraus folgt
doch dann kannst dass du zeit nur so
verstehst einander rein und dann mit
übersetzt du aber dann aber einen
wichtigen punkt derzeit nämlich die
ineinander stellung und daraus folgt
dass deine theorie eigentlich wirkt
problematisch ist also kurz gesagt der
song wird kant eine vereinigung der zeit
vor und damit gehen ganz andere probleme
einher
das problem der freiheit des problem des
nichtstuns weiter
es wurde jetzt sollen es jetzt aber
nicht weiter hiermit jetzt immer
betreffen und jetzt wollen wir hier zu
diesen netten herren hier übergehen
heißt jemand von irgend wer das ist
marien heiliger genau waren noch ein
bisschen jünger und schaltet diese
schöne violetten hier 1889 bis 1976 und
der hat ein buch geschrieben und das
trägt den titel
sie wissen es sie raten zu sein und 227
der wahl der gute herr 38 jahre alt
und dann lesen wir jetzt ein paar
leitfragen erst noch nämlich wie
verhalten sich haltiges zeit theorie
verhält sich die zu der bisherigen
theorie wie verhalten wir hängen
zeitlichkeit und da sei existenz
miteinander zusammen
wie verhalten sich vergangenheit
gegenwart und zukunft nachhaltiger
zueinander
wer hat den vorrang und warum also
haltiger nimmt jetzt hier eine
gewichtung vor die die verschiedenen
nancy ekstasen derzeit betreffen
vergangenheit gegenwart zukunft und
jetzt dürfen sie dreimal raten welche
der drei ekstasen vergangenheit
gegenwart zukunft verteidiger die
wichtigste ist was sagen sie mehr ist
für vergangenheit
wer ist für gegenwart wer ist der
zukunft ja inzwischen gegenwart und
zukunft
da wird sich dann entscheiden aber er
hat doch so einen gewissen vorrang der
zukunft ebenfalls mit diesem text den
wir jetzt hier lesen werden
[Musik]
also jetzt beginnt das ganze erstmal
ganz komisch mit einem neuen begriff
nämlich mit dem begriff des ta sagt er
sagt das dasein ist nun selbst
hinsichtlich seiner existenz eigentlich
oder und eigentlich erschlossen
existierend versteht es sich so zwar
dass dieses verstehen kein profis
erfassen darstellt sondern das
existenzielle sein des faktischen sein
können ausmacht das erschlossene sein
ist das eines sein denn dem es um dieses
eingeht der sinn dieses 1 dh der sorge
der diese in ihrer konstitution
ermöglicht macht und mich das sein dass
sein kann es aus der science sind des
daseins ist nicht ein frei schwebendes
anderes außerhalb seien selbst sollen
dass sich verstehende dasein selbst als
ermöglicht das sein des daseins und
damit dessen faktische existenz so jetzt
erzählen sie einmal kurz und was geht
sie eigentlich verstehen sie das und
wenn ja was
also anhand der rede können sie schon
erschließen dass sich hierbei um einen
phänomenologie handeln also eben nicht
mehr jemand der so wie kant technisch
gilt obwohl es schon eine sehr
technische regeln sie hat jetzt hatten
sie sich gemeldet
aus
dass er quasi so oft das symbol das uns
da sein und es seien an sich gehen und
versuchen sie auf verschiedene balken zu
betonen dass alles andere wegfällt ist
kein junger darum das sagen haben
stattdessen gibt es nicht
genau also das dasein ist ein sein dms
sagt eine andere stelle in seinem sein
um sich selbst es geht also dem dasein
um sich selbst und das dasein ist eben
ja was ist das da sein dann manche
würden sagen es ist das existierende
individuum
ich habe mein seminar zusammen mit herrn
professor buchheim gegeben über sein und
zeit nicht alles lesen konnten aber viel
oder professor buchan hat gesagt wir
dürfen jetzt dass das eigentlich zu
verstehen als ein individuum als als
objekt was existieren naja gut
vielleicht nicht nur als ein individuum
als jemand der existiert und im
existieren eben immer schon über sich
hinaus und diese was ich genau sein
nennt heutiger dass sie wie er es nennt
also ein wort mit drei bindestrichen
dafür zugang
die drei nimmt das in der welt sein das
in der welt sein
ja also das dasein dasjenige was
existiert und das sind natürlich
menschen das ist klar
da ist existiert eben nicht nur für sich
und das ist der verdener descartes
vorwirft weil er sagt descartes denkt in
seinem chef der subjektivität immer nur
das individuum für sich und dann kommen
wir ganz stellen sonst götzis muss wie
können wir denn dann die außenwelt
beweisen wenn wir doch nur von uns
selbst gewissheit haben man sagt heute
das stimmt von vornherein nicht weil das
ich existierten die nur so für sich
sondern das nicht existiert als ich
immer nur insofern als es nach außen
gerichtet ist das ist immer auf etwas
aus dieses aus seinem tiger im anschluss
an edmund husserl intentional i tät das
ist die gerichtet hat als er sagte
kaarst dich von vornherein dass ich das
ist nicht nur auf sich selbst gerichtet
sind
im gegenteil dass ich es immer auf
anderes gerichtet auf die ganze welt um
uns herum existiert und deswegen stellt
dieses problem des skeptizismus der
außenwelt gar nicht weil eben mit dem
ich schon die außenwelt gesetzt ist weil
ich ohne bezug auf die außenwelt gar
kein existierendes mich ist sagt
heiliger
kann man darüber streiten aber
jedenfalls hat so einige punkte für sich
und jetzt geht es ja und das faktische
sein können dass sein können das ist die
möglichkeit damit kommt dann die zukunft
und spielen das ist das was ihm noch
voraus schwebt und diese sein dass sein
können
der science sinn und die sorge die sorge
die sorge ist auf etwas außerhalb des
seins gerichtet der existenz des da
sonst aber indem sie nach außen
gerichtet ist ist dieses äußere eben
wieder auf das dasein sind gerichtet
dass es dieses in der welt sein also das
dasein ist immer mit dem auf basis
gerichtet ist verbunden indem er sich
aufrichtet
wie auch immer sich das dasein auf das
alles gerichtet sei es durch die sorge
sei es durch den sinn usw überfordert
oder durch das verstehen verstehen es
immer verstehen von etwas sorge es immer
sorge vor etwas zu haben damit bin ich
das ganze wieder in eineinhalb hinein
das interview offene des ursprünglichen
existenzielle entwurfs existenz
enthüllte sich als vorlaufender
entschlossenheit vor laufen meint in der
zeit vor laufen heutige spricht eine
andere stelle auch vom vorlaufen zum
tode
für ihn ist die existenz immer etwas was
angesichts des todes als der letzten
möglichkeit gedacht müssen unser leben
so denken dass wir immer schon bis zum
tode vor gelaufen sind weil nur durch
diesen maximalen kontrast unser ganzes
dasein erfassen können unser ganzes
dasein unsere existenz ist durch die
zeitliche beschränktheit definiert was
ermöglicht dieses eigentlich ganz anders
da sein sehen sie licht der einheit
seines gegliederten struktur ganzen
formal existenziell gefasst ohne jetzt
ständig den vollen struktur gehalt zu
nehmen ist die vorlaufen die
entschlossenheit das seien zum eigens
den ausgezeichneten sein können also
wieder die möglichkeit die zukunft der
gleichen ist nur so möglich dass das da
seine behaupten sondern ereignissen
möglichkeit auf sich zukommen kann und
die möglichkeit in diesem sich auf sich
zukommen lassen als möglichkeit aus hält
das heißt existiert also da kommt nicht
etwas auf das dasein zu sondern es kommt
auf sich selbst zu und das nennt
existieren dass die ausgezeichnete
möglichkeit aus haltende in ihr sich auf
sich zukommen lassen ist das
ursprüngliche phänomen der zukunft haben
wir als eine definition dazu wenn zum
sein des daseins das eigentliche bzw ein
eigentliches seien zum tode damals
gehört dann ist dieses nur möglich als
zukünftiges in dem jetzt angezeigt und
noch näher zu bestimmenden sind zukunft
meint hier nicht ein jetzt das noch
nicht wirklich geworden einmal erst sein
wird sondern die kunst der das dasein in
seinem eigenen sein
auf sich so kommt das laufen macht das
dasein eigentlich zukünftig so zart dass
das vor laufen selbst nur möglich ist
sofern das dasein als sein dass
überhaupt schon immer auf sich zukommen
das heißt in seinem sein überhaupt
zukünftig alles klar
sie lachen daraus schließe ich dass ich
es verstanden habe sehr gut
die ist doch eigentlich ganz klar oder
wer also ist so also er spielt jetzt ein
bisschen den worten aber das finde ich
das ist eigentlich bei heutiger das
interessante als er bricht diesen
traditionellen wortgebrauch auf und sie
sehen hier eine tendenz zur ethnologie
als er versucht immer bestimmte
begrifflichkeiten die sich so in unserem
alltag eingeschliffen haben aufzubrechen
indem er auf die ursprünglichen sinn
verweist gesagt die zukunft kommt von
der kunst
das kommt vom kommen jetzt ist es aber
nicht so dass die zukunft dass da etwas
auf uns zukommt sondern dass wir auf uns
kommen müssen als wir müssen zu uns
werden
ich kenne vielleicht verliert den spruch
werde der du bist also da kommt nichts
fremdes auf und susann diese zur und
vollzieht sich in uns wir kommen zurück
jedenfalls direkt der punkt ist hier der
das also es ist immer wieder dasselbe
heiliger nimmt einen wichtigen begriff
stellt ihm ins zentrum und sagt wenn wir
das wort das wort man eigentlich
betrachten dann kommt es von diesem wort
das hat also diese etymologie und diese
etymologie des wortes zeigt uns dass wir
das wort ganz anders verstehen wollen
sollen also nicht so dass die zeit auf
uns zukommt sondern wir kommen auf die
zeit oder wir laufen vor
das ist nicht so zu verstehen dass hier
also wir sind hier da sein weil die
zukunft kommt auf uns zu
so ist es nicht sondern es ist eher so
dass das dasein vor läuft auf den tod
zum tod und dadurch aber auch dadurch
eigentlich erst auf sich
kommt jetzt kommen im vorlauf zu sich
die zukunft zu sichern kommen zu sich
hin kommt
der tod ist eben die äußerste
möglichkeit unsere existenz zeitlich
verstand das ist der letzte horizont vor
dem jetzt zehn mäßig ist gar nichts mehr
über den hinaus sind mäßig geziehen
mäßiges gar nicht gedacht werden kann
ist strittig
denken sie mal an überlegungen gedanken
an ein leben nach dem tod
heiliger scheint mir jetzt prima fazio
das stimmt ist eine andere frage
alle religiösen und so weiter und andere
optionen auszuschalten und ich würde das
bestreiten sind ich würde sagen selbst
was nach dem tod ist ob es jetzt es gibt
oder nicht spielt jetzt keine rolle
nach toten ich würde sogar sagen unser
vor laufen ist nicht auf den tod sondern
unser verlaufen ist ein auf den nach auf
das sie liege was nach dem tod ist und
ob es das gibt oder nicht aber ich würde
das noch ein bisschen modifizieren weil
wir durchaus den tod ja immer
transzendieren indem wir über den tod
denken an den tod denken sind wir über
den tod schon hinweg ich glaube heilige
hat den tod hat hier eine zur
gegenständlichen vorstellung von tod in
dem er über den tod reden sind wir immer
offen aus wie auch immer
einer sagt genau also ist es die
eigentliche möglichkeit also er sagt
hier und die möglichkeit in diesem sich
auf sich zukommen lassen bedeutet das
ist existiert
zukunft meint hier nicht ein jetzt das
noch nicht wirklich geworden
erst sein wird sondern die kunst sondern
die kunst in der das dasein in seinem
eigenen sein können auf sich zu kommt
also dass ich würde so beginnt das
dasein sieht seine eigenen möglichkeiten
oh ja aber die eben dazu in der zeit
lieben und in dem es seine möglichkeiten
sieht die vom toten natürlich auch
bemessen werden kann es sich erst als
dasein konstituieren heute gedenkt es
immer so erst aus den möglichkeiten
heraus können wir unser dasein bestimmen
ist ja klar ein ich na also unsere
möglichkeiten geben unseren
handlungsspielraum und sind freiheits
spielraum und erst in diesen
handlungsspielraum entwerfen wir uns
planen wir leben alle lebensentwurf
das heißt eigentlich die zukunft ist
nichts was auf uns zukommt und wir
gelaufen erst mal in die zukunft hinein
und kommt dann aber auf uns zurück weil
die zukunft geben unsere existenz
definiert sagen
ja
das ist mir gedanken kurzfristig genau
er substanziell
dieses könne eines menschen dadurch
kommen dann ins leben aus sich zu weil
zb
das heißt diese weise realisieren
warum das so zu sagen gut ja genau so
kann man es auch noch sagen
also es sind die pläne es sind die
entwürfe wir ganz zu beginn zeigt ist es
einfach unser freiheit spieler also eben
die möglichkeiten definieren unsere
rahmenbedingung die existenz die wir
erst ausfüllen können und dieses
ausfüllen dieser möglichkeiten dieses
rahmens das ist der entwurf durch pläne
und wir müssen dann wie sie richtig
sagen diese entwürfe natürlich auch noch
realisieren
dann kommen wir eben wieder auf uns
zurück und so fühlen wir uns als frei
wesen dadurch wieder erkennen dann
realisieren
dieses zitat noch am schluss die
vorlaufende entschlossenheit versteht
das dasein in seinem wesen haften
schuldig sein dieses verstehen besagt
dass schuldig sein existieren übernehmen
als geworfener grund der nichtigkeit
sein übername der geworfen hat aber
bedeutet das dasein in dem wie es je
schon war eigentlich seien die übernahme
der geworfen hyde ist aber nur so
möglich dass das zukünftige dasein sein
eigenes das wie er sie schon war das
heißt sein gewesen sein kann nur sofern
da sein überhaupt als ich bin gewesen
ist kann es zukünftig auf sich selbst so
zu kommen dass es zurückkommt eigentlich
zukünftig ist das dasein eigentlich
gewesen das vor laufen in die äußerste
und eigens die möglichkeit ist dass
verstehende zurückkommen auf das eigens
nicht wesen gewesen da sein kann nur
eigentlich gewesen sein
wenn es zukünftig ist die gewesen haid
entspringt in gewisser weise der zukunft
also was macht er jetzt hier
kurz gesagt er bringt die drei
dimensionen oder wie es denn wird
ekstase von oder zumindest die zwei von
vergangenheit dem gewesen um zukünftigen
zueinander aufeinander er sagt es kann
keine zukünftig kite geben ohne gewesen
zu sein also es muss er denken dann
zusammen und paradoxerweise erwächst
nicht die zukunft aus der vergangenheit
sondern die gewesen heiden springt der
zukunft also eigentlich würden wir doch
sagen erst kommt die vergangenheit das
gewesen und da rauskommt dann die
zukunft sagt aber andersrum
hier ist aus dem sich in zukunft
entwerfen wird überhaupt dass wir ein
wesen haben und dass wir uns
konzentrieren
erst in dieser zukunftsausrichtung
deswegen scheint mir hier ein gewisser
vorrang der zukunft zu existieren
gegenüber der vergangenheit und der
gegenwart aber wir werden da in der
nächsten sitzung noch einmal ausführlich
zu sprechen kommen können weil wir ja
dafür ganze 90 minuten zur verfügung
haben